[Music]
the happiest guy in the world right now
is jimmy carter because now he's out of
the history books for being the worst
president ever that would give him a
poor grade because of the way we left
afghanistan i think that that was
terrible
i guess i'll leave it at that i would
give him a very poor grade because of
that
like great
tactics there i guess you would say
a seven and a half out of ten try not to
be mean here but because because again
he was not given a great situation to
begin with
but he hasn't done anything to improve
said situation and
yeah three four max
give him a five i don't know i don't see
much going on that much change
[Music]
a honestly f
what's a middle letter in the in the
alphabet
you probably don't want me to answer
that question z
i said i'd give him a z
stinks
i just don't think he's doing much of
anything but messing up the country i i
don't know where to start there's
inflation the border uh forget about it
found a bacon now yeah i love bacon who
doesn't like bacon
and uh it's nine dollars a pound now
forget about it this guy's got to go
[Music]